okay
so let me sort of just recap what we
discussed last time
fairly quickly and then we want to move
to empirical evidence on a variety of
settings
we might not get through all of the
slides that's fine
in that case we'll just discuss some of
this in recitation
so let me sort of recap what
in their 1979 article um were
proposing based on a bunch of
experiments and empirical evidence that
they had collected
so their theory
is called prospect theory what they
proposed versions of prospect theory is
essentially versions of reference
dependent utility
have been used are used prominently now
in economics
so the first thing that they proposed
was what matters what the carrier of
utility is is
changes rather than levels that's to say
it doesn't matter for you necessarily
how warm it is it matters kind of what's
the change of temperature compared to
yesterday
it doesn't matter that much how much
money people have in total it matters
how much the changes
relative to what they had previously
more generally what matters for people
is essentially a certain
consumption or the like relative to
reference point as opposed to an
absolute
terms second loss aversion this is
losses
loom larger than gains and we had some
evidence of that in the last lecture
that's to say if you lose some money or
some consumption
or anything else grades etc
a lot relative to either your status quo
or to your expectation
looms larger is more important hurts
more than a gain of the same magnitude
in the positive direction and number
three which you talked about
quickly is what's referred to as
diminishing sensitivity
that is um people are risk averse in the
gain domain but risk loving in the last
domain
that's to say um um if you are for
example if you think about distance
time chance and the like going from zero
to one
or from one to two from two to three is
more important for you
than going from like 100 to 101 101 102
and so on essentially
uh the further you'll go away from like
your
status quo your reference point uh any
marginal changes like diminishing
right and that's true for both the gain
domain and um
uh the loss domain so these are sort of
the main three characteristics
related to what kind of first we call
the value function we can think of this
as essentially a version of the utility
function
there's a fourth characteristic which is
probability weighting which we're not
going to talk about at least
for now are there any questions on these
three
things so far
okay so now
prospect theory is then what kahneman
and versky were proposing they were
essentially saying like
instead of having concave utility which
i showed you um uh
last week instead your utility function
may look like
this and what are sort of the features
of this utility function what what are
the
three key features that i just showed
you how they're showing up in this
function here
yes uh c minus where is the changes
right so the carrier of the utility
function so what we have here is like c
and r
uh c is like consumption that could be
anything that could be apples that could
be bananas that could be uh
sort of how much money people have
available to consume overall
the carrier of the utility function is
not c itself it's c minus r so it's c
relative to some reference point r
that's exactly right
so and if r is the status quo if r is
how much do we have right now or the
person has right now
c minus r is a change relative to the
status quo
notice that r uh we're going to talk
about this a little bit could be also
other things it doesn't have to be
necessarily the status quo
it could be also people's expectation or
their goals or their aspirations for the
future
right the key part is however what
matters is the first thing i was saying
like
it's changes rather than levels changes
relative to some
reference point or consumption relative
to some reference point that's number
one yes
yes uh the curve flattens out which is
diminishing
exactly the curve flattens out in both
directions that's diminishing
sensitivity
it's essentially concave in the in the
gain domain of the domain where like
c is larger than r and it's convex in
the last domain where c is
smaller than r right
and that's exactly the issue that
essentially the first the marginal
change going from like uh say one to two
is relatively large compared to a
marginal change going from 10 to 11
that's both going in the right direction
in the gains domain and the left
direction and the last domain
uh yes um for the loss of version um the
left side is cheaper than the right side
exactly in particular there's like kink
in and this function
uh when you look at zero where
essentially um
the gain and loss domain was c equals r
uh the gain and loss domain
intersect uh there we have a kink in the
in the value function and the utility
function uh which essentially exactly is
the last domain
at the last aversion which is like going
to the right it's less deep than going
to the left
but differently if you lose if you're
sort of below the reference point
that's more painful than being the same
amount of uh
units to be above the reference point
that's number two that's essentially
exactly the last aversion
so i just wrote down all of that again
let me repeat caro the utility has
changes relative to the reference point
excuse me rather than levels second
there's loss of version there's a kink
at zero in this function and three
there's diminishing sensitivity which is
concavity and gains and convexity in
losses
any questions on that
now a key question here is i'm going to
sort of flag this we're going to talk
about this a little bit at the end
of the lecture we're going to talk to
this a little bit in the next problem
set
is kind of like how is the reference
point determined and does it matter
as i said before in kanaman firski's
work a lot of the reference point is the
status quo
so they essentially postulated the
status quo is what would really
what matters originally i think people
have moved towards saying like the
reference point and this is what kossig
and raven and others have
written down in their models of
reference dependence utility and
and and recent more economics work is
what really matters is
expectations so what do you expect
to consume or to have and so on that
matters that sometimes coincides with
the status quo
for example if you have a house the
status quo is that you have a house you
probably assume that you have a house in
the future
uh these things coincide if you think
about wages et cetera what seems to
matter often is not so much how
much what people's wages are right now
what matters is like what wage gains and
so on do they expect to
receive in the future and they evaluate
their future their their outcomes in the
future
uh not necessarily to like the current
wage but rather what they expect they
would get
in the future okay and so here's an
example
and you'll have some problem sets
questions again this is problem set
three
which is not posted yet but but will be
uh of that kind
which is you might have like reference
dependent utility over
uh this is just a very simple example
over shirts and money so you have
essentially two different domains you
have essentially losses and gains over
both of those domains
you have a reference point which is rs
is how many shirts you might have you
have a reference point rm how much money
you might have
now what's important here is that
essentially when you think about buying
a shirt
or or selling a shirt there's going to
be two dimensions
which you have to sort of consider if
and when you think about the endowment
effect of mugs and so on
you have to consider not only
the losses on gains and shirts but also
the losses can gains in money
so that's to say if you're trying to buy
something you're going to get like a
gain in shirts relative to the reference
point if it's unexpected
but you'll also have a loss in money
similarly if you're going to like sell a
shirt you're going to have like a
loss in shirts but a gain and money on
these things and interact
now what's the value function the value
function as i said before it's usually
concave in the gain domain and convex in
the in the last domain
there's a kinkex zero it's deeper on the
left uh then on the right usually we
think
uh the relative slope is about like two
2.5
okay so um so one version of that would
be uh
this function that i wrote down again
there will be some
problem such questions etc sort of to
clarify uh that
but one key question here is then uh
what are the different domains and
that's kind of like a question like of
mental accounting we'll get to this like
in the second half of the course
the question kind of like what are the
different categories do you have like
shirts do you have like
uh pants uh sweaters or is it just for
clothes overall
um or like when you think about like
earnings and uh consumption et cetera is
it daily consumption is it weekly
consumption is it monthly consumption
so there's lots of questions on like how
to exactly specify this utility function
these questions are mostly um unanswered
in the literature so for now for us in
our purposes
we're going to essentially assume there
is a value function given and then
sort of work with with that
any questions on that
okay great so now we're going to talk
about the number of different
applications we talked a little bit
about already
about the endowment effect and about
insurance i'm going to skip this
um there's some of this already in in
recitation and the problem sets
we're going to particularly talk about
labor supply and employment decisions
essentially how much do people
like to work in is effort or people's
work decisions are they reference
dependent
uh we're gonna talk about finances what
was mentioned last time already about
investment decisions when do people sell
and buy stocks we're going to talk about
housing when do people decide to sell or
buy a solar house and at what price
uh we're gonna talk about sports in
particular marathon running uh
and golf um uh and a little bit about
this
some papers in domestic violence we're
gonna talk very briefly about and then
we talk a little bit about firms how do
firms think about pricing
um uh and so on and what what is sort of
like the market response to
to reference dependence that's to say
given that we know there's lots of
reference dependence on the world
uh how should we now as a firm or like
uh
uh treating other people how should we
think about um how does that affect our
our own behavior
or how maybe firms interact with us okay
so let's start with um a labor supply
let's start with a very simple
um example suppose there's a worker in
the following situation
she can work freely choose how many
hours she works every day
and there are frequent temporary changes
in her hourly
wage now there's different relationships
between
wages and hours per day you could always
work the same
number of hours you could work more
hours on the days when wages are high
or you could work a few hours and days
when the wages are high
what are sort of standard theory say
what should you do
yes two two why is that um
because that maximizes your expected
value
for time right so if if hours are
effortful you usually don't like to work
you should work during the hours when uh
uh
when your payment is the largest uh
that's right so
what about option number one why might
option number one
be optimal so what you're saying is
exactly right uh depends a little bit on
on something else and what is that
like why might you choose number one
anyway
um habit farming is nice
yeah there could be sort of habits
exactly or it could just be that it's
really effortful to work like 12 hours
in one day maybe there's like kids at
home or maybe there's like you know it's
just really
tedious to work at some point you just
want to go home and do other stuff
so it could just be that working beyond
you know like say eight or nine hours
per day is really tough to do
so then you might say i'm always going
to work eight hours i'd love to work
more
uh but that's difficult to do so
essentially it's just to say if the
effort function if the
effort as a resp function of hours is
convex and you might sort of say
keep it the same surely what you don't
want to do as
number three working few hours and days
and wages are high
unless you know effort costs are
particularly high on those days so it
could be that it's like really super hot
or it could be like it's super tedious
to work on those days and you might say
then you don't want to do it
but assuming that's not the case you you
kind of want to avoid this because
for the same number of hours you're
going to make less money um overall
right and sort of here's a concrete
example suppose wages
five hours an hour on day one and ten
hours a day on day two
so there's three strategies you can work
eight hours in both days you can work
six hours on day one nine hours on day
two
or the opposite nine hours on day one
and six hours on on day two
so if you do that you can do you sort of
calculate how much that is you can
essentially work eight hours on both
days you get 120 hours you can work
six hours and nine uh uh uh
uh on on days one and two which makes
120 hours
at dollars as well or you can
essentially do um the opposite which
makes you 105
dollars this is what i was saying like
options three doesn't make a lot of
sense
um unless effort costs are particularly
high on certain days when the wages are
high
we're assuming that away for now um and
so now option two
and this is what you were saying
essentially saves you an hour overall
you work only 15 hours instead of 16
hours and you make the same amount of
money
now unless sort of the effort court
unless the ninth hour is extremely
costly for you to do you might not want
to to do that
okay now why might you do
uh something else uh instead or what
sort of
where does reference dependence come in
here
yes i see on the high wage day that i've
made more than the less waste day so i
feel like stopping maybe
and why am i why would you stop like
what's what's what's causing you to stop
uh
[Music]
yeah and so yes and but
so what's the what are you evaluating or
what's the
or what happens for example if you work
only six hours on
on a different day like how much do you
make on the six hour day i guess which
would be
uh maybe thirty dollars right and so
what are you comparing that to i guess
so suppose you on average you want to
make a certain amount of money which is
50
60 and so on now if on sundays you make
a lot of money and on sunday you make
very little money
you might sort of evaluate that
separately and say on that day i'm
essentially in the last domain i'm like
below my target or
below my expectation and so if you
evaluate your
utility that way you might sort of not
want that because it feels essentially
you're below
a certain threshold it feels kind of
like a loss relative to your expectation
and so on
and you might be inclined to work a lot
of hours
instead on the days when you make a lot
of money why might you stop
yes you might have like a target that
you expect to hit every day to cover
your expenses and if you
feel like working less you can still
reach that target
right so if your target your reference
point is essentially a a certain number
you might reach that target quickly
because your wage is pretty high on that
day
now once you reach that target you might
say well like now your utility function
is relatively
not very steep anymore relative to being
in the last domain so it's like flatter
so then you might just stop relatively
soon because essentially any marginal
earnings
are not really valuable for you anymore
okay any questions on that or comments
so why do we want the wage changes to be
temporary here what's an issue here when
you sort of try to look at this in the
data
suppose i had like persistent wage
changes yeah so you can have like a
frame of reference
yeah you want to kind of keep the
reference constant so in some sense if
wage changes are permanent
uh then you get essentially income
effects you'll be a lot richer overall
if they're only temporary essentially
you can sort of argue that essentially
your expectation should be the same
and once you reach once you have a lot
more money then your classical model
should actually say that there should be
income effects
the neoclassical model only says
essentially the inner classical model
says
you should essentially aggregate all of
your income and say it doesn't really
matter like whether you earn it in
monday or tuesday wednesday or thursday
you should look at like how much are you
earning overall depending whether you
earn
sufficiently much um uh you're gonna
work fewer or more hours
now if you earn like a lot because your
wages doubles or whatever you might
actually work few hours
not because you reach a reference point
on a given day it's just because you got
a lot richer and then you decide it's
not worth for you to work that much
so we're kind of trying to avoid that
we're trying to have only permanent
temporary changes which is to say
forgiven wealth overall um
on any given day it shouldn't matter
whether you earn the money on monday or
on tuesday
so essentially if the wage happens to be
really high on tuesday you should be
working more earning more on tuesday as
opposed to on monday
uh now what i was saying is if you
reference the pendant you might actually
care about this you might care about on
monday you didn't reach your target
therefore you want to work more
on tuesday you reach your target very
quickly and you work
uh uh less even though the wage is
actually really high
okay now
strategy one might be optimal even in
the neoclassical model if effort costs
uh are convex this is what i was saying
is if it's really sort of costly for you
to work nine hours you might say i
always work like eight hours i wanna
have a certain amount of money for my
children and so on
um so the extra hour if that's really
really painful you might not want to do
that
uh we don't think that's necessarily the
case in in so many
uh situations um the question is like
can we really say that strategy
three that's the strategy of doing the
opposite of working like essentially a
lot of hours and wages are low and few
hours
when wages are high can we really say
it's a mistake well it depends on kind
of like whether the effort costs are
correlated with wages so if cab drivers
for example make really high wages on
some days and low wages on
other days it could just be on low low
uh
wage day it's really um uh it's much
less effortful to drive around
so you would do like more hours it turns
out when you actually ask
a cab drivers they actually prefer a
busy day is actually preferred when
they're customers as opposed to just
driving around and looking for people so
we don't think that's actually true
but in principle you would have to sort
of think about uh that
now uh there's a long literature uh
starting with camera at all on
uh cab drivers a lot of that essentially
is pre
uber like uh collecting trip sheets um
from
cab drivers now there's lots of like
uber data that's like essentially much
more powerful in some ways
so there will be probably more papers
using uber and lyft etc data on that
um but what camera doll did at the time
was
they essentially looked at a typical cab
drivers that rent their cab for 12 hour
periods for a fixed fee
and within this 12 hour window a driver
can choose the hours freely so you just
get your cab that's not yours you rent
it for the day and then you can
essentially choose how many hours you
want to work
and their wages how much money they make
in any given hour varies by a lot
there's like you know uh the weather
varies there's subway breakdowns
conferences and so on and so forth
there's lots of variation in how much
money you make on a given
day so then they have like trip sheets
that look at like how long
cab drivers work and their overall
earnings and so they can essentially
back out the wages from
from each day and then look at like how
much do people work on uh
days when wages are high versus wages
are days when wages
are low and then they essentially find
the basic finding and that's a finding
that's sort of been contested in the
literature and many people are found
are confirmed subsequently or and others
have not but i think eventually people
have sort of
settled on this hours are negatively
correlated with wages so when wages in
particular are unexpectedly high
uh cap drivers tend to work a few hours
and again the and this is like not for
permanent changes but for transitory
changes if surprisingly on a given day
people get
more money then
[Music]
drivers work few hours and that's very
hard to explain for the neoclassical
model
because essentially like you shouldn't
care about like whether you make the
money on monday on tuesday as i said you
should care about how much you money
you make overall and how many hours you
uh work
and so it's very hard to explain this
and sort of the explanation
uh that cameradoll and others um
we're testing or or arguing is
essentially this has to do with um
reference dependence and so what's being
evaluated in a reference dependent way
or how do we think about this
yeah i have a question yeah um how did
they
rule out the possibility that like maybe
there's like um
reverse causality maybe i'll say where
none of the cab drivers want to work
that much because of supply and demand
but they just go up
so so that's to say like effort costs
are high
so usually it's to do with like other
drivers so let me let me actually get
the
so let me defer this for one second i
have like a slide on like confounds
and then we can see whether it addresses
your question and then get get back to
that
but that's a good question so
uh what is being evaluated in reference
dependent way here what are people
looking at in terms of
where is the reference point in the
evaluation here
yes um i guess if you're a cab driver
you
kind of say oh i want to make like this
much money today and then you just kind
of like work until
you feel like you've made it up and then
you just stop right
exactly you have to pay your fixed fee
for the day or for the month or whatever
but like there's an implicit uh
fixed fee for the day so you kind of
want to make at least that much money to
make not a loss you probably have some
positive target in some way and saying
like i want to make uh
pay back like my um my fee plus you want
to make some money for the day
and minus sort of expenses and once you
reach that target
you are in the gain domain below that
you are in the last domain
right and so the daily income
essentially and that's essentially sort
of like
uh money after paying back the fee but
you could also get uh it's essentially
your
uh uh what's being evaluated in the
reference append network
what's the reference point it's some
daily target that you have often it's
like expectation
and so on and sort of essentially how
much you think
you will make and then what's the
feature of the value of a function that
explains the phenomena well it's loss of
version if you're like falling short of
the target
essentially your marginal utility how
much when you drive another hour or
another trip
the marginal utility that you get to see
it then the value function is very steep
below the target
is very high once you reach the target
it's very flat and then essentially you
you you tend to stop does that make
sense yeah
okay great so um the main takeaway here
is although if drivers often stop at
their daily income target
um drivers with a higher wage reach
their targets faster and they work few
hours
again that's like variation uh uh uh
within
drivers um across days and so that
there's lots of
subsequent work and debate regarding
this finding that the debate is still
ongoing
for example one reason paper looks at
like tips that people
uh drivers get unexpectedly so sometimes
drivers get like large tips sometimes
get small
tips it depends a lot like when in the
day they receive the tip if they receive
it really early versus late if they sort
of get to their target
and essentially the target seems to be
adjusting over time uh but overall this
is sort of getting a little bit at your
question um
uh where we think it's not sort of
aggregate um
supply but the debate is over are still
ongoing but overall we sort of think
that
lots of labor supply decisions when
people have daily decisions of how many
hours to work and their
wages vary depend on uh reference points
uh and might sort of potentially be at
least um suboptimal or put differently
they could people would could work few
hours
um and trying to sort of adjust their
overall amounts you can actually when
for a while like this you can ask your
uber lyft drivers what they're doing
and so on and see whether they're a
reference dependent uh a
driver so they have reference dependent
preferences now what are sort of
potential alternative hypotheses one
question one issue could be like
liquidity constraints
this is like for example if you just
don't have enough cash and you have to
pay back
for uh your fee for the day or for the
next day you might want to not work only
very few hours on a given day
uh it turns out that drivers who own
their own medallion exhibit the same
patterns
they could be things like fatigue it's
let's just say it's really tedious to
work on certain days
when wages are high we don't think
that's going on in part because drivers
themselves
they say it's actually easier to drive
with more passengers
again recent papers in fact can also
control for this and so on so we don't
think it's actually
um fatigue and this is i think what
you're saying uh the last one is
unobserved shocks so some shocks that
affect all drivers labor supply at the
same time
example you know there are some days in
which all drivers get the flu
uh fewer drivers will work and those who
will work uh
work few hours and those who work get
uh get higher wages
we that's a little bit trickier for them
to to
to to roll out in part there's other
papers other studies afterwards that
sort of try to
get at this usually um um
yeah for this specific data that's hard
to do i think for the other
data where people have essentially not
just
daily so this is essentially trip sheets
so they have what they're using mostly
is like daily wages overall
they don't even have the wage they only
have the um
the overall um uh earnings and then the
hours and then they sort of impute the
wage dividing the two which causes some
other trouble
but once you have like uber data once
you have like specific trips in
particular also tips and so on
you can look at on a given day uh when i
get
like a high tip versus a low tip uh uh
how do
you can you can look at like you can
predict essentially how much i'm gonna
earn on a given day
so suppose you you predict that i'm
gonna uh earn hundred dollars in a given
day
now i have like say fifty sixty dollars
now i get like a large trip and like a
tip and so on that gets me over that
threshold you can look at where their
stop
you can look at the exact same thing
when i have like only twenty dollars and
they get a large ship to a stop and so
on so you can essentially control for
all of that
and then do within a driver comparisons
like for trips
uh that happen to be large or small that
you happen to get in a given hour and
then you can sort of deal with like
overall market conditions
i think even better in the future there
will be sort of like experiments and so
on where you can look at
when uber and lyft try to incentivize
their workers and so just say
essentially
sometimes pay people more and unless
randomly sort of explicitly randomly
because they want to kind of learn about
how to best incentivize the drivers and
then you can control for everything
because it's like explicitly random
whether a certain driver gets like
high versus low uh uh wages or sort of
trip fares yeah okay
um are any questions on the um
on the uh labor supply
yes um i'm a bit confused about the
unobserved shocks
because like if you get like a really
large tip that doesn't necessarily like
predict that the rest of the day you
have higher wages if you kept working
okay like you just get this really high
tip and then you might be like oh
today's a lucky day i can stop early
but if i had worked more this day i
wouldn't necessarily be making
continuously more
than normal right so in the unobserved
in the large tip
example the assumption is exactly or
what they show in the paper this is
subsequent work not this specific work
what they exactly show in this type of
paper these are sort of random events in
a sense it's
really precisely not predictive of your
future uh
uh earnings it's random now one
interpretation that you have is to say
well it could be that you kind of have
some expectations about your future
earnings
that could be particularly high or low
it's like i got my lucky day
and so on and so forth that is hard to
rule out and sometimes if you had
rational expectations uh that's hard to
explain for the neoclassical model
what's harder to rule out is to say
you know i now think like i got my lucky
draw for the day and that's it and i'm
not gonna
uh i get any lucky draw again let's just
call it a day
that is hard to rule out but what is um
hard to explain for the neoclassical uh
model i think we can sort of reject is
to say
if you just think this is a shock which
really in reality it is and you just
happen to get a bunch of money on given
day
uh just randomly uh that is
then the reference dependent model can
sort of explain why you stop early
because you it just puts you
tips gets you over the reference point
the neoclassical model should just say
depends on like essentially how many
hours you want to work on a given day
it's nothing to do with a target because
essentially again it doesn't matter
whether you make money on monday or
tuesday or wednesday you should just
care about like your overall amount of
money that you make
overall but that's a good question
okay so now um a second paper is on the
housing market
so what is the natural reference point
for housing
markets or like how do we think about
housing prices or how do you think about
i guess
a few of you will own a house but how
would you think about if you if you
owned a house
how do you think about uh selling a
house what is a natural reference point
yes uh whatever it was for or like how
it changes
yeah so exactly so uh the previous
purchase price it turns out it's a very
very salient thing for owners people
really know how much they paid for their
house
it's like a huge expense in their life
they really remember it was like three
hundred thousand five hundred thousand a
million et cetera they know exactly how
much they paid
and that even asked people people know
exactly how much they uh the majority of
people know exactly how much they paid
for their um home
now one claim is that loss of version
makes people unwilling to sell
their houses at a loss and so what they
would then do is they ask essentially
for higher prices if a loss relative to
like their their purchase price and
let me just show you um exactly what i
mean by that
uh gina risa and meier have um boston
condominium data from 1990 to 1997.
um luckily for them there's lots of
variation or fluctuations in the housing
market during that time so the housing
market went up a lot and then it went
down a lot and went up a lot
now suppose you have two sellers a and b
who both want to sell their house or
their home in 1994.
now what we can do is we can look at
these two people who suppose they have
very similar houses
based on observable characteristics and
location and so on and so forth
so once they have really comparable
houses we can now look at
people who seller a purchased their
home really early on in 1989 that person
happens to be quite unlucky because they
just bought the house really at the peak
of
uh i guess the housing boom at the time
or
seller number b who purchased in 1991 uh
uh that that person was relatively lucky
the bot essentially had a price where
at a time where the housing market was
relatively low and uh
appreciated quite a bit so now we can
look at these two people
and ask the question uh is seller a or
seller b
more likely to sell their house and and
the hypothesis is that
seller a will sort of view this as like
a loss this seller will essentially just
say i'm losing money here
i don't want to sell and that seller
might essentially ask for like a higher
listing price and wants to like more
money for this house because they don't
want to make a
a loss on that uh sale well seller b
says i'm actually gaining money anyway
so let's just sort of like uh
post whatever you think is actually the
expected market price might be happy to
to sell at a lower price
compared to seller a okay so one thing
we can look at essentially are listing
prices how much do people want for the
houses
effect second thing we can look at is
like actual sales prices
you know are you now like selling this
at a higher lower price and number three
we can look at like how long is the
house on the market
how long does it actually take to sell
it that's a quite costly thing to do to
have your house on the market for quite
a while because essentially
often people then don't already move
somewhere else or they don't kind of
live in the house because they have to
sort of show it and make it available
for
showings and so on so it's a costly
thing to do you really
don't want to you have your house on the
market for like several months
but it's sort of the broad idea claire
what we're trying to do
okay so what predictions um
do you want to test but you want to test
whether house owners are reluctant to
sell their house when the current market
price is below
the purchase price so the ideal
specification is essentially the
following we look at the list price on
the left-hand side
and then we are going to run a
regression that looks at some constant
that's just kind of like time trends et
cetera
plus a beta which is the coefficient of
interest or one coefficient
of interest is of the actual market
price how much is the thing worth
and then delta on the loss is like how
much do you lose relative to your
purchase price now if people were not
reference dependent what should we find
what would be the predictions
like the neoclassical model what should
we find here
yes
exactly delta should not matter it
shouldn't matter how much you lost or
gained in that house
uh what should matter is like what is
the actual market value you should
essentially try to
be willing to sell it or not beta could
be
you know it doesn't have to be one it
could be like everybody
pays above the actual market for some
housing bubble or whatever beta could be
like
1.1 or whatever you might be uh that
depends on essentially sort of aggregate
conditions and so on
but delta really should not matter when
i'm trying to sell you a house you
should ask like what's the
actual market value and i should um
essentially then based on that
uh uh put it under market um on that
listing price
uh but what might be the case is that
the loss actually um
matters now one problem here is that the
actual market value is not observable
right so i don't actually know what the
market value is because that's like
endogenous that's part of like the
transaction
so what can i do instead or how do i do
this
yes by asking people like would you like
would you take this trade
what they say right so you can look at
actually the market
outcome overall you can look at like who
buys it and what's the actual purchase
price
now that might also be endogenous to
like the listing price right so if you
think you know the people who are lost a
verse are
listing their houses too high relatively
compared to what the market value
actually is
it might actually be sold at a higher
price so that could
that's hard to interpret it could just
be that if you sell it at a high
if you list it at a very high price and
wait for a long time you also sell it at
a higher price
but doesn't mean that it's actually
worth that much it just means that like
you happen to find
a buyer who happens to be willing to pay
a lot and that's more likely when you
wait for a long time
which is not necessarily optimal because
it's actually quite costly to do that
but you're saying something else which
is like asking them about what they
think but what are the characteristics
that we could look at or what data
could we look at
like if you had like zillow data or data
on like essentially a bunch of these
apps where you can look at houses
what data could you get yes you'd look
at like the houses like in the
neighborhood like similar
houses exactly what redfin and zillow et
cetera do these days is essentially they
have these algorithms that try to
predict
uh the actual market sales price and
what they tend to do essentially is look
at
exactly as you say surrounding houses
that are similar in some characteristics
they look at the number of they look at
the square footage they look at the
number of uh
bathrooms and rooms in general they look
at like sort of like location and so on
and so forth
and then you can predict um uh
how much uh and sort of they look at
also time trends and so on
how much is the actual market value but
it's essentially fundamentally it's like
a prediction exercise you can try to
predict
uh what the actual value is and that's
exactly what uh genovese and meyer do
they do
some more fancy things that try to get
at like other
unobservable characteristics and so on
but the essence of this is exactly a
prediction exercise where they say
let's just look at uh the
characteristics of this house let's try
to predict what the market value is
and then look at the loss which is
essentially the difference between the
previous selling price and the expected
selling
price truncated from zero because
otherwise it's a gain
and then we can look at uh does it
really seem that like when people are in
the lost domain when their losses
positive
are they now um selling their house or
trying to sell their house
at a higher um price yes
how would you account for something like
recent renovations like since the last
listing and
relative to any other similar units or
causes
and nearby right
so um that's tricky to do and i don't
think they have this in their data so
what you'd have to assume here and
that's
perhaps reasonable is to say that when
you look at sort of this picture
that um seller a and zellerb did not do
differential renovation depending on
when they bought the house right so if
you said
it's fine if people have done
renovations for example this is what i
was saying about the beta on the actual
market value
if you systematically underestimate or
overestimate how much people renovate
and so on or maybe you know the housing
market is really hot or whatever
that's okay the main issue is like that
can't be correlated with the
uh uh the loss here so if it's the case
that people who may
who lost a bunch of money in terms of
like their housing prices sort of like
tanked
uh if those people have done more or
less renovations then you're in trouble
with your estimates
yeah is the expected selling price the
estimation of actual work value
correct okay yes
um so now what what generation meyer
find is and there's more detail to that
but essentially the main finding is and
that's a
fairly solid one there's a bunch of
different specifications is a 10
increase in a perspective loss if this
loss coefficient the difference between
the expected selling price and the uh
purchase price
uh if that's 10 percent higher than
essentially the list price is 2.5 to 3
percent
uh 3.5 percent higher and then these
effects so like people list the price
the house at a higher price if the house
is at a loss compared to like a similar
house who's not at a loss or like
it was in the game domain these effects
then translate
into higher uh sales prices and the
lower hazard rate of sale
that's to say people actually sell it at
a higher price
so it's in fact you know it's hard to
say here what's optimal versus not it
could be that overall people are like
uh you know it's actually a good thing
to do that depends a lot on essentially
like your opportunity costs of
of money in terms of like or you know
your how
costly is it for you to keep the the
house on the market for a while
but essentially um uh people have a
lower hazard rate of sales that's to say
it just takes them a lot longer to sell
the house
that tends to be very costly to do so
but you know if you you know just
otherwise would have your money in the
bank and you have another place to stay
and you don't really care
maybe then that's fine uh but we surely
have like real effects in terms of like
uh people list their houses as high at
higher prices people
sell them at somewhat higher prices and
people also keep them longer
on the market okay yeah
is this the same analysis if it's gains
in the
value of the house
so essentially what we're doing is we're
implicitly comparing losses versus gains
right so so that gains
the gains here would be in the actual
market value
already as it is so it's
so but essentially what you implicitly
do is you create when comparing
implicitly this is what i was saying
here
when you look at this picture implicitly
what we're doing is we look at people
who are
um losing money compared to people who
are gaining money
and explicitly implicitly asking like is
the increase in the gain sort of
predictive of that
sorry the the increase in the loss is a
predictive of like your
uh listing price now it's hard to do
this at the same time
for for gains because essentially an
increase in the market
price overall is this like that sort of
culinaire
in short essentially that's hard to
separate you could do the same analysis
and you wouldn't find that for the gains
in part because
essentially explicitly what we're doing
is increasing losses to gains
okay uh okay so then there's another
piece of evidence that sort of tells us
perhaps this is not optimal if you look
at people who are
owner occupied compared to investors so
they're people who essentially invest in
houses and they sell houses and they
sell lots of houses over time
those people have much lower uh
endowment effects if you want for houses
so they exhibit this behavior a lot less
but people who live in that house who
bought that house for them it's mostly
like the only house they live in it's
the main purchase that they have
for them it's essentially their house
for which they don't want to make
a losses for them these effects are
twice as large compared to the
investors and that's perhaps some
evidence that uh this is not optimal
behavior in a sense of the
sort of the professional investors they
presumably know pretty well
uh how to price their houses so if they
do this behavior less
uh presumably that's that's a sign that
that there's some form of a mistake here
um going on
second there's some evidence in john
list has some work on this
overall is to say that experience can
mitigate reference dependent
effects essentially if you do a lot of
trading if you sell a lot of houses and
so on
then you might still feel losses of
losses and gains
but you might sort of have a lot more
experience with this you kind of know
that this is happening sometimes
and you might be less prone to these
types of effects because you kind of
know that you shouldn't be doing
this you shouldn't sort of have your
feelings of losses and gains
get in the way of making profits so
there's some people who would argue that
this is very much consistent with like
markets over time or exposures to
markets and several predictions
experience
makes some of these effects go away and
john list has some
separate evidence on this on traders of
cards and so on
okay so now next we're going to talk a
little bit about finance and stocks
so interestingly yeah sorry on the
previous um study why is this a
reference dependence
on information um owner and i
think that my house is worth this amount
and i'm just
really anchored to believing that that's
the problem
right so one thing you could say is like
that uh so what you always have to make
the argument is like people who are
losses compared to who are at gains so
you look at your
investor a and b they might have like
additional information
on uh how much the house is worth so it
could be for example that seller a
knows a lot about this house it's like
very beautiful and so much light and
this and that
um and therefore they paid a lot
therefore they have private information
that it's worth a lot
therefore they listed at a really high
price so there's some specification here
that look at this
what you see is this is like columns two
four and six
which is uh the residual from the last
sales price
what is that that's essentially the
difference between at the
time when previously the house was sold
what was the prediction of the market
price then and how much was it sold so
it's kind of like how much did you
over uh uh how much did you overpay if
you want relative to what we expected at
the time
presumably that's reflective again using
the same prediction method
so if you thought you know it's really
beautiful and lots of windows and this
and that lots of light and
really quiet and so on if you overpaid
at the time
that should then sort of pre predictive
of the listing price
and sort of controlling for that then
should make this go away
what you see however is this is um
there's some of that perhaps going on if
you
compare for example columns one and two
you see that the effects goes down a
little bit but it's still there quite a
bit what's this is why i was saying like
25 to 35 percent
uh that is exactly right that's a big
concern and there's a bunch of sort of
robustness et cetera checks in this
specific study
but that's exactly right there could be
sort of unobservable information that
the
uh owner might have about the house that
is not in zillow or in any sort of
return etc
predictions that's available for the
public that's a great question but i
think it's
uh to the extent that that takes care of
it it's sort of uh the authors have
thought about that uh yes um on the
following slide
when you talk about the differences
it's how do you control for like the
selection bias about the people that
may be the ones repeatedly selling
houses
exhibit this last and therefore like
stay in the market
versus a change in those individuals
behavior
right that's a great question so the
question you're asking is essentially to
say
and that's in fact a great um sort of a
segue into like behavioral finance which
is to say suppose there's some people
who are really sophisticated
they don't have certain uh behavioral
biases maybe they're not philosophers
that makes you like a better investor
say and therefore you stay in the market
overall i think from this observation
that i have here i cannot tell you is it
like select is it just
is it just that people um
is it experience or is it selection so
the question kind of is
when people are investors
do they do the effects of reference
dependence of gains and losses go over
go away over time essentially like maybe
the first second third time i feel like
really a loss in terms of making a
bad investment but in number house
number 20 i'm just like that's like as
usual and i shouldn't
really care very much is it that this
goes away or is it that like the people
who are particularly lost a verse and
sort of essentially
uh engage in this type of behavior in
terms of like uh
over uh listing too high of a price um
for losses
these are sort of like that investor in
the housing markets and they sort of
are essentially driven out of the market
so that specific setting um i don't
think we can necessarily
account for that i think in the uh
studies by john list it's very much
people argue it's about
experience but again there could also
some part could also be a
selection i think so now in the
so i think in some sense either way
um uh uh i think the the evidence that
the investors are doing this behavior
last sort of tells us something about
like
this is probably not at least
financially optimal
for you to engage in this type of
behavior it might be privately optimal
in some sense if you really feel bad at
like selling your house at a loss you
should probably
list it at a higher price because that
sort of limits you your losses
that's just what the utility function
looks like it's not necessarily a
and the sub-optimal in the sense of like
uh how you feel afterwards
it might be sub-optimal in terms of like
how much money you make or how much
money you have eventually
uh on how much you pay for keeping your
house on the market and so on
for an extended period of time um okay
so does that answer your question no
yeah okay
so um so behavioral finance is an
interesting field because
for quite a while economists thought
that sort of neoclassical assumptions
are in fact most likely to hold in
financial markets and why is that
why do we think what and some of this
already i mentioned but
why are financial markets
particular why might i think that
financial markets are particularly
efficient
yes well you might think that financial
markets are very competitive
and so it's actually the ones who can
get rid of their behavioral biases that
benefit
exactly so it's very much like sort of
the chicago
economics assumption is to say so uh
financial markets are extremely
competitive if now i'm an investor
who has various behavioral biases
presumably i'm going to lose some money
one way or the other
well if markets are really competitive
in the long run i cannot stay in this
market without sort of being
a driven out so essentially the market
favor sort of
results oriented rational and selfish
behavior so people are not rational and
so on and so forth will be eliminated
from the market
eventually there's two parts to that
that's true like across firms that's to
say like you know there's some firms
that are better than others
but also within the firm if i'm an
investor and i'm sort of like um
advising clients and the like and i'm
sort of not very good at this and like
essentially i have certain payable
biases that are not optimal in terms of
like making
money for people presumably i will not
be promoted presumably i will be driven
out of force fired from the
the company um eventually so
surprisingly in fact
finance became one of the most
influential and most fruitful
applications of be able
of the psychology and economics so
behavioral economics there's lots and
lots of work in behavioral finance
the reason being perhaps not necessarily
because people are um so some people are
presumably driven out of the market but
surely not everyone
but in particular because there's like
great data in finance like there's lots
and lots of daily data in terms of like
things that you should be doing compared
to like what models would say
so it's a really great way of like being
able to test models or test essentially
predictions of the neoclassical model or
behavioral theories and so on
so that's why behavioral finance has
been very influential
because there's so much data available
for people to in fact
test theories and then you know why is
it that people are not entirely driven
out
i think often the case is that even if
you're right for example even if you
write that you can
predict and if you watch some like um
movies on the financial crisis and so on
even if you're
right about like in the long run the
market is going to tank well actually
it's going to take you a lot of money
and then you know often you know if
everybody is wrong
prices will go up for quite a while so
it's not actually clear that in the
at least in the short medium run we'll
be driven out of the market um
uh uh quickly but that's sort of a
separate topic
okay so now um one uh a reason why or
one way in which reference dependent
behavior might be important in finance
is uh people might be differentially
likely to sell winners and hold on to
losers
uh financial stocks that was mentioned
last time as well
so what terry odin did in 1997 is like
he had in fact
a brokerage accounts from a national
weight uh a brokerage house
which had all trades and prices for i
guess 87 to 93.
in some sense a little bit like
old-fashioned a sense of like you
shouldn't be like in
individual trading and so on you should
just hold the stock market or the s p
500 or some index funds and so on
here these are people have like hold
individual stocks and sell and buy them
uh one by one and so during each trading
day then what our dean can do is he can
look at
evaluate each stock in the portfolio and
look at this as a loss relative to a
purchase
uh relative to the purchase price so you
can look at essentially
the portfolio and say there's losers and
winners
he only has like data on trading day so
you can look at like you know
other losers and uh winners when they're
being sold
and um he can look at the net realized
uh gains and realized losses
so if you sell a stock and it's like
essentially above the purchase price he
calls it the realized um
uh again loss and if it's um sorry if
it's
if it's a losing stock it's old it's a
realized loss it's below the purchase
price
if it's above the purchase price it's
going to be a realized gain
now one thing you could do is like
compare the number of realized losses to
the
number of realized gains does that work
or is that reference dependence or what
do we what do we learn from that
yes
right so i could look at like the
realized gains and the number of
realized gains and the number of
realized losses
but what's the problem with that i think
that's exactly right but like what's the
underlying what's the problem with this
approach
like how does this depend on the stock
market going up and down
yeah so that's a separate issue like you
could look at the magnitudes
themselves and you look at sort of like
depending on where you are
how does that matter but what about just
a number of gains and losses
like what if the stock market goes up a
lot what are people going to
sell or
right so he does have that i think that
i'm asking for something very
basic which is if the stock market goes
up a lot you'll have lots of winners so
you're going to realize lots of
if you just sell randomly stocks gains
and losses and you just don't care
you'll have much more realized gains um
compared to realized losses just because
your stock market went up a lot
similarly if the stock market went down
you will find that people have way more
realized losses compared to realized
gains and it looked like i'm really
trying to sell the losers but it's not
i'm actually selling to losers you just
have a lot more
losers that's all i was asking i think
he has actually the information about
the purchase prices
so what he then does is something very
simple it just looks at people's
portfolios and says like how many losing
stocks do you have
what's your propensity to sell the
losing stocks which is what he calls the
plr
the propensity proportion of losers
realized the same he does for the pgr
which is the poor proportion of gains
realize
so it looks at each person when they
sell something they look at like how
many losing stocks you have how many
winning stocks you have
and then you look at like what's the
probability of you selling
any of those depending on the winners or
losers
so what the main finding then here is
that the pgr the proportion of
gains realized is larger than the plr
that's to say that's called what they
call like the disposition effect
which is the tendency to sell winners
and hold on to losers
does that make sense okay and so why do
we care about that or why is this
actually bad is this it's necessarily
like sub-optimal behavior
why do we care
yes
[Music]
there probably shouldn't be an overall
bias towards
like selling like users and that
probably isn't like an overall
like effective strategy right so it
depends on essentially how well the
winners and the losers gonna do
it turns out so in principle you would
say well winners and losers should have
the same
expected return regardless of their
winners and losers in the past that's
essentially the efficient market
hypothesis just to say
past uh price changes should just not be
predictive of like future
uh uh momentum or price changes overall
because the current price should have
incorporated essentially all information
that's available at this point in time
so to that degree it shouldn't matter
actually what you sell you could just
randomly sell stuff
now you should not sell a lot usually
there's commissions involved in these
trades so like essentially you shouldn't
sell anything that's essentially leading
to over trading
uh odin has another paper that shows
essentially in particular men tend to be
overconfident and and how good they are
trading and they tend to over trade and
that's really costly
it turns out that like in their specific
period
um in fact there's momentum and that
used to be the case
uh quite a bit in that period of time
which essentially is to do the winners
actually doing better than the losers by
quite a bit more big margin
that is to say you should have actually
did exactly done the opposite if
anything you should have sold the losers
and keep on keep the winners because
they are
in fact making more money in the short
and medium run in that period
okay um there's also the the investors
sell more losers and winners in december
um this is what you see here
why is that
yes exactly this is for tax reasons so
that's actually happens to the
shin portable i was in the economic
support and actually if you paper in
this
so there you can essentially realize
losses and that that
reduces your taxes overall um
exactly but overall essentially what's
happening is that people do seem to
engage in this behavior
um in a pretty striking fashion they
seem to be losing um
quite a bit of money from that
okay let me mention uh at least the
marathon running and perhaps the golf
example and then we're going to move
towards like
uh prices and firms how do firms react
to these biases
but what i'm trying to do here is
essentially show you a bunch of
different settings and essentially if
you look at different settings in the
world
there's lots and lots of different
settings where reference dependence
seems to matter one way or the other
seems to be important in shaping
people's behavior
so um this is a very nice paper about
marathon running
finishing times these are many many
marathons they have lots of data on
finishing times for people
so the lot of large numbers would
predict that if you look at essentially
people's finishing times
if people have different talents and so
on and so forth the finishing times
should look something like this
okay there's some people are faster some
people are slower but overall there
should be some
um uh smooth distribution that
essentially is like log normal or
whatever you want it to be but
essentially it should look something
like this
so my why might it not look like this or
what's what what might people do instead
yes they may say i'll be 4 30 and then
you might see bunching
at certain points like four hours four
thirty five hours five thursday
right so exactly as you say it might be
that people have reference points
not in terms of like status quo here and
the like reference points might be goals
or aspirations you might say i really
want to run the marathon in four hours
or for 30 or
five hours if you want and then um what
the marathon times actually look like is
something like this
and in particular it seems like people
have lots of goals of reaching something
like um and
you know as you if you look at this
distribution what you see is exactly as
you predict
um uh if you look at the half hour or
the
even the quarter hour sort of points
there's essentially bunching from below
so essentially people seem to be
if they're like at pace or finish at
four
hours in one minute they try to sort of
speed up and just make it to like three
um 59 and so
you even so you see a bunch of bunching
um at the half hour slots
you see actually much less at like six
hours and 30 minutes or something seemed
to like few people have actually goals
once you've
like run the marathon in six hours and
30 minutes which is probably what i
would do
you know it doesn't really matter
whether you like 6 31 or 6 29
uh but there's very ambitious people who
want to like finish in like 4 30
4 hours or 3 30 and the like and there's
a bunch of um
bunching from below there so you see the
same for like
a quarter hour times a little bit less
of that
um and sort of that's consistent with
the reference point here being like
a goal and aspiration you want to reach
four minutes you want to brag to your
friends and so on and it's not so great
if you do that and say i
finished in four hours in one minute as
opposed to if you say i finish below
four hours now when you look at the
effort at the
end of the race what is it what would
you expect so what we have here on the
x-axis
is people these are like the uh 40
kilometer pace these are like in 30
second increments this is kind of like
during the so the marathon is 40 um
uh uh 42.195 kilometers
um so what i'm showing you here is like
essentially people the 40 kilometer pace
people
are ranked by the 40 are distributed by
the 40 kilometer pace
uh the first 40 kilometers now what you
would you expect for people so there's
some people who
like were at pace for like to reach um
355
and some people at pace to reach four or
five and so on what is it that you would
expect people to do when you look at
like how fast people run
uh towards the end the last two
kilometers of the race
yes
exactly and this is what you see so low
means like you're running fast
so this is like uh minutes per kilometer
i think
or relative minutes per kilometers so
what you should expect is like people
who are
just below the goal or people who are
essentially just above the goal in fact
these are the people who speed up okay
so
um and this is exactly what you sort of
see is the people who are
just below the four or four minute mark
or some people who are like just above
they speed up to just make it uh to that
goal and sort of um
allen and i'll have like a sort of
analysis of this essentially what they
find is that
um everybody gets sort of slower towards
the end of the race but if you're sort
of in reach of of reaching the goal by
form
for uh the reaching the time of four
hours you're gonna
uh slow down less so speed up a bit to
just reach that
uh a specific goal okay
uh let me show you one more thing of
sports which is like a
a golf so how does golf work in case you
don't know um
you you hit a ball um with a club from a
tee into like a hole
um the way this works is um there's
usually uh four rounds of 18 holes
um this is there's very convex
incentives
in the golf tournaments so you get a
bunch of money if you win if you're sort
of at the top
for an average performance essentially
you don't make that much money i mean
you make
good money but you know the the the
prize the money is really in terms of
like
uh when you do really well so now what
is par
par is like how many um strokes how many
shots do you need to
um how many shots a very good golfer
should require to complete a given
a hole so um so par is usually four
three four or five um shots uh and then
eagle is like two below par
so if like you have a par four hole if
you do two shots that's an eagle
if you do three shots in that case that
would be a birdie four would be par
borgie would be one above par and double
bogey would be
uh two above par okay so knowing all
that
and so what ends at the what matters for
golf at the end of a tournament is like
how many shots do you make in total so
how can we now look at reference
dependent preferences here
in this setting
yes
yes the reference is the par now suppose
you are
putting which is at the end you know on
the green uh what are you going to do
what kinds of behaviors do you expect
yes um well it depends so if you are
under par
then you might try like you're shooting
for birdie or you're shooting for a car
and it's a long cut
you might try to make sure that you get
into the hole whereas if you're already
over
over par or double over car you might
try to play a little safer to make sure
you're not
way over it right so some of this is
about like risk preference is how
risky your shots are you can another way
to think about this is kind of like how
much effort do you put in your shot in
some sense you to the extent that like
you can put in
you can sort of allocate attention or
really focus an effort
maybe that's sort of limited over the
course of like 18 holes and four
uh uh four rounds uh of each of those
you know you might sort of put in might
try particularly hard to do well on
shots that make you
reach par compared to shots that might
get you like a birdie or
or even better and so this is exactly as
you say
the fairly obvious reference point for
each hole in golf is reached par
importantly it doesn't matter um uh
whether you have birdie
par and bogie versus par par and par
essentially that gives you exactly the
same
amount of shots overall but um
not what pope and schweitzer ask is the
question like
putters um more likely to to make their
par
uh than their birdie parts right so
essentially uh depending on like
are you at possibility at losing or like
at gaining uh
to you essentially if you're worried
about like losing par
are you gonna behave differently
compared to like when you can make a
birdie which is in the game domain
potentially
the same you could say about bogeys
where like you're already in the loss of
men because you're already doing
terribly and you're
trying to avoid like a double um vogue
so now what they find essentially is
their power puts a much more
likely uh to be made there's like two
three percentage points more likely to
be made compared to equivalent birdie
puts
the authors rule out a bunch of
different explanations it doesn't have
to do with like heterogeneity
player ability they even have sort of
like gps information of exactly where
the ball is compared to the whole and
they do all sorts of comparison of how
hard the shot is
they don't think it has to do with
learning from earlier puts and it seems
to also not have to do with like whole
specific preferences some holes are
really hard and some poles are really
simple and easy and so on so it doesn't
seem to be uh
to do with any of that so again that's
sort of another
instance of like reference dependent
that seems to be in quite a few
settings let me sort of skip the deal
and no deal tv show which we can
do briefly in recitation and talk a
little bit about prices
and firms
so one fact is that we see in the world
is that
demand often responds more strongly to
price increases than to price decreases
of frequently purchased items and we we
already discussed that last time is to
say
um so usually people have a reference
point in terms of like either the price
they pay or the expenditures on certain
items
so now something becomes more expensive
what they tend to do is they essentially
reduce how much they
for example gasoline or the like they
tend to then sort of just reduce
uh uh their expenditures because they
have like a budget for
say gasoline or certain items and so
what they tend to do is then the
reference point is either the past price
or the past expenditures
and uh uh people tend to sort of be lost
a verse than over
uh other certain um their uh
expenditures
over the specific uh uh domain
now that then leads to so if a firm
knows this so essentially if you know
that essentially people react a lot
to price increases um
compared to price decreases um that
leads to sticky prices essentially so
raising your price above like a pass
price is very costly
because you lose a lot of customers from
doing that so now
lowering your price below the pass price
won't actually do very much essentially
you're not going to
generate a lot more extra demand plus
raising the price in the future is
costly you know essentially once you
lower the price it's hard to get up
anymore so
uh for like these frequently purchased
items you see a lot of price stickiness
and price equalization
um across markets across time and
products
now that's sort of one thing about like
prices in the world that you would see
but more generally i want to sort of ask
the question in the last few minutes
about like
if you were a company um suppose you did
an internship somewhere in the summer
they told you
um uh you know you you took behavioral
economics uh
uh hopefully you learned something but
like what can we learn about
um uh about like the firm policies and
so
on now that you know about loss aversion
what would you tell them they should do
[Music]
yes having a really high price and then
people
right so that was previously it was
mentioned is to say you could sort of in
particular when you introduce
um a price a new product and so on you
might want to start at a high price and
then sort of like lowering them and
people really like having deals and they
feel
good about it notice that that doesn't
work so well for like
products that you already have and so on
because then essentially once you start
with a high price people get really
upset and they
you will lose the customers but once you
introduce like a new product
be it like an iphone or be it like some
whatever new uh
uh computer or whatever it makes a lot
of sense to start with a really high
price that sort of sets the reference
point and then people sort of feel like
they go deal get good deals um overall
what else could you do yes
you could offer any single glory
temporary discounts
the way you keep your reference point
the original price and your
property for our list
exactly that's what a lot of companies
tend to do they tend to do essentially
these like special occasions
we had like black friday and the like
it's not like exactly as you say it's
temporary it's not like a thing that
prices are uh
uh permanently lower it's a just right
now you get this like great deal and
then
things go back to normal and somehow you
have to hope that people don't sort of
adjust the reference point uh towards
the temporarily lowered
um price what else
[Music]
[Music]
than yes yes
so if you shop online you might have
wondered lots of companies have this
thing i'm like oh you can order whatever
you want you're like essentially it's
like free returns and you kind of wonder
like
that seems like a bad deal from the
company's perspective because people buy
a lot of stuff and send it back
the hope is exactly as they say it might
be just in part people like to
experiment and they like some stuff and
not others and that's worth doing it
but the hope in particular is to say
well i want you to try it out for a
while you get used to it
then the endowment effect kicks in you
value it more he essentially becomes
yours
and uh then essentially you become lost
of hers
towards that by the way i should have
mentioned uh this is really
a fascinating book by chaldini who's
uh talking about the psychology of
persuasion he spent a lot of time with
like sales people and particular sort of
car sales people and so on trying to
learn of what are they actually doing in
markets
and he has these like amazing stories of
like sales people what's all sorts of
tricks they they use
it's psychologically extremely rich and
interesting in terms of just trying to
understand what people do
and that ranges from things like you
know once you um
uh purchase a car they let you like test
drive in the car and you sit in it and
it feels like yours and then
you know or when you try to buy a house
you know then people would say like oh
you know this will be your living room
and this is where your baby is going to
sleep and like
you know there's lots of sort of ways in
which people make sort of something feel
yours and really try to sort of get the
endowment effect um
uh to kick in if you were to work in an
insurance firm what would you do like
somebody who offers insurance in one way
or the other
or products that offer insurance in some
ways
yes we talked about this a little bit in
the previous class
but uh this is why i think companies
will sell things like apple care or
operational warranties because they can
they know they'll make money off of it
because people tend to overinsure
exactly there's lots of different
products where there's extended
warranties and all sorts of like things
like apple care etc
where people are like very risk-averse
what it looks like presumably loss of
errors
um where in fact you know they actually
the claim rate tends to be very low
so you can make a lot of money with this
by saying like yes i'm going to exchange
it in this and that
because essentially it doesn't happen
that often at the end of the day
even if there's like moral hazard or
other issues so people not treating
their stuff that well once they have
insurance what about wage setting
like when you when you set your your
employees wages
yeah could that be linked to mass
unemployment in recessions because
you know that if you lower the wage then
morale will go down a lot
and you could actually decide just to
kick them out
right so exactly so there is um
there is um a large uh literature
on uh wage stickiness um
essentially exactly as you say
where people are extremely reluctant to
lower wages
companies are very reluctant to lower
wages because essentially workers are
really unhappy
so once you and these are like often
nominal wages or real wages it doesn't
really matter that much but usually it's
nominal wages
people really really dislike nominal
wage
reductions and so now in some times when
uh companies would actually need to
lower wages
and sort of to be able to keep workers
not to make losses
companies might rather sort of fire some
workers
rather than sort of lowering the wages
for everybody because essentially
the remaining workers once you lower
wages for everybody everybody would be
unhappy if you just
fire one worker everybody else will be
less unhappy than about their wage
reductions similarly
firms are reluctant to hire people at
lower wages if there's other people who
make higher wages because people really
dislike wage dispersion
so essentially overall you want to to
avoid wage cuts as much as possible
and that leads to essentially then the
macroeconomic inefficiencies and people
have argued in particular it leads to
like
unemployment because essentially uh
wages are not going down as much as they
should
in recessions and that's bad for firms
and therefore they hire fewer workers to
retain fewer workers overall
i think i mentioned we mentioned all of
those uh uh kind of things
so now um another thing that sort of
that's sort of like what firms are doing
now another thing you might think about
is like what are you going to actually
do in your real lives
um i think there's many different things
that you can actually think about is
like
the framing of situations for example
can make a big difference if you
present something to your friends
different options whether you whether
you present that as like gains or losses
makes a big difference potentially
managing people's expectations is really
important if there's like
some big goal that they could reach or
some lower goal they could they could
reach if you sort of oversell the high
chance of like
reaching some big goal they might reach
the other goal that's actually pretty
good might
feel like really disappointed about that
be it in job search or the like
so managing people's expectations
including your own expectations
seems really important there's something
about aggregating losses and gains which
essentially is to say
since people seem to be um uh
uh risk averse over gains and um so
since the value function is concave
over gains and convex over losses um
what you should do is potentially as
like be really careful about like
when you give people uh a positive or
negative
um feedback or like bonuses and so on uh
you might want to sort of be
be careful like uh whether you uh
aggregate the losses or
so aggregating losses makes sense
because it's essentially it's like um
convex in the lost domain as opposed to
like you want to give small increments
of gains
um overall now one thing that i do want
to mention is like you want to be kind
of very careful with last framed
incentives
there's a company who is trying to do
this um uh and
trying to give essentially these are
like car manufacturers were trying to
give essentially their car dealers
incentives
um sort of uh targets
in their um for their sales of of their
their cars what essentially happened at
the end of the day is like there was a
bunch of um
multitasking is like the company or the
car sales people were essentially
selling certain cars but they're not
others and we're essentially
multitasking and then sort of
reverting uh sort of reallocating
efforts to one thing versus the other
which then seemed like a really good
idea there was a recent evaluation that
sort of showed that
um that was actually pretty bad idea and
the company would have lost a lot of
money overall
if this had been uh scaled we're gonna
have this the the dlr no deal and the
specific paper and recitation to tell
you in more detail
because i want to move towards social
preferences next time
uh so as i said next time we talk about
social preferences bring your laptop and
i'll send you further instructions
thank you